hell's gum as man's care to back let's
play around some more with some phase
ready last time I didn't really follow
the instructions so it should work
better now
hi my name is boots it's so weird like
laughing and then you see yourself
laughing in your laughing water because
it looks funny I can't do anything about
our stupid steam thing but tell me does
the booty jiggle oh this is so much
cooler than last time my face when I see
that is hey you why don't you subscribe
to for a pie oh you are going there
barrage sorry
can't look at you you're too ugly oh god
I have a sneak peak oh oh it was nasty
oh alright I'm opening holy [ __ ] is this
what LSD feels like I'm probably
enjoying this too much why does he want
to keep your eyes open yeah yum yum yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum my
anaconda don't my anaconda don't my
anaconda don't want none unless you got
buns hun yeah oh yeah but what about her
ass [ __ ] ass jiggle can I have
somebody when I saw a booty for the
first time I am sakya ha ha you don't
even know how to say it okay listen up
ha ha
ah you're never gonna learn I'll take on
my Oh Oh take my belly oh that feels
good oh that feels good mmm eyelashes
but that's this but yeah and I'll do it
alright let's do some karaoke it's got
what it takes
so tell me why can't this be love
straight from the heart
do it do it again
other when there was a little fun do it
again can i it's been a while you know
now suck your nips Pamuk come on come on
come on give me a come on spin away come
on that moment you realize you're a
burger do you know where we can get some
drugs and alcohol I can see the stars I
can see the galaxies holy [ __ ] what is
that that is the biggest hot dog I have
ever seen as godly hey how you doing
girl
how you doing how you doing girl hey how
you doin
are you telling me what out of crackers
there is crackers
can I have one please that ass is huge
praise the Lord for that alias iPod I
had that ha I'm a big I wish you could
breathe fire with this one that'd be
awesome
oh sorry I was just pooping out the
bunch of meatballs that I stuck up in my
butthole that's what we do in Sweden oh
my god thank you
alright fire it's time for your demo
alright I'm ready
alright Bret I gotta end this episode
there but if you enjoyed go ahead and
like and favorite and subscribe and
become a bro today that's all brofist I
can't so you're gonna have to eat me bro
finished